this streamer is broke and homeless in
Japan because of a donation refund my
twitch business is now officially back I
I'm in Bank bankruptcy the streamer
Relic Chris said he used donations from
his community to travel Asia but months
later one of the larger donations was
unexpectedly charged back which left him
in the red and stranded in Japan Chris
got a lot of flippant responses not
quite understanding how this happened
but he explained that a lot of IRL
streaming essentially relies on
sponsored travel most of importantly
Chris says that he's okay and has a
place to stay in Japan and people are
giving him donations to make sure that
his bank account is no longer in the
negative